Hello and welcome. This is Active
Bookstream number 1.6
on governing continuous transformation.
It's January 17, 2023. Off to you.
Bleu good morning everyone or
good whatever time of day it is for you.
We are the Active Inference Institute of
participatory online institute that is
communicating, learning and practicing
applied active inference. These are all
of our social media links where you can
find us if you're looking for us
outside. This is a recorded and
an archived live stream. So please
provide us with feedback so that we can
improve on our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and we
will be trying to follow good video
etiquette or live streams other than my
cat to feel free to interrupt whenever
she said. You can reach out to
us if you would like to get involved
with any of our ongoing projects or live
streams or propose a new project.
And today we are going to discuss this
is bookstream number one,
six. So this is our 6th
contextualization video, or the
contextualization video over chapter
six. And we are going to study Governing
Continuous Transformation reframing the
Strategy Governance conversation by
Bijan Khezri who was nice enough to join
us and discuss some of his ideas with us
last week. This video is just an
introduction to some of the ideas
presented in the book. It's not in a
review or a final word in any way.
So we're just going to jump right in and
introduce ourselves. So I am Bleu. I am
a researcher in New Mexico, and I will
pass it off to Daniel.
I'm. Daniel I'm, researcher in
California and looking forward to the
continuation of the series. Tyler hey,
my name is Tyler. I'm a practitioner,
not a researcher. So I lead product and
protocol design Ant 4K protocol and I
also do governance on the limits of Dow
tooling with Medigo. All right. Bleu.
Awesome. So today we're going to get
into part two of the book, so Free
Energy Governance. And we're going to
discuss the first chapter in part two.
Part Two free Energy Governance. And
we're discussing chapter six. And
there's kind of two sections and
actually Bijan broke chapter six for us.
So there's two sections of chapter six,
the upper echelon View and the
predictive processing framework.
And here just a little intro to part
two, free Energy Governance. Bijan says
free Energy Governance introduction a
novel cross hierarchical generative
framework that uniquely applies the
triplet of structure, cognition and
capabilities as the building blocks of
the firm's generative models.
Specifically in the context of
continuous strategic renewal in
distributed and discontinuous market
environment. Essentially, six force
theoretical perspectives together lay
the foundation for this new conversation
structure, upper echelon view, and
prediction processing framework. So
that's what we're going to discuss
today. And then I'm assuming that the
next chapters going forward are going to
focus on cognition, which encompasses
attention based view and an activist
approach and capabilities encompassing
dynamic capability, view and
antagonistic neural networks.
Perspective, structure, cognition, and
capabilities form one integrated system.
Under Free Energy Governance, failure in
any one domain is likely to challenge
firm survival. The framework's core
propositions outlined at the end of this
chapter summarize Free Energy
Governance's ambition for a practice
relevant theoretical contribution as
both the generative logic of
organizational governance as well as an
early warning system predicting
corporate decay. So Tyler, do you want
to jump in and read the abstract here?
Except to the apprentice loan view and
prediction processing framework address
Free Energy Governance structural
dimension. Indeed, upper Echelon is the
size of strategic decision making.
However, UEV suffers from several
limitations. There is no explicit
consideration for the board of directors
and the linkage between the upper
Echelon and to the rest of the
organization. I. E. The coupling of
Governance and operational challenges is
unidirectionally top down and therefore
at best, incomplete. How the field data
can systematically topped up or Echelon
and influence their values, precession
and attention remains a black box.
Prediction processing framework embraces
structure more holistically addressing
the hierarchical disconnect and more
importantly, the circular causality
between top down predictions and bottoms
up stimuli.
Sparing messages.
Dissonance bearing messages occur at the
firm stimuli level bottom close to its
resource markets long before top
leadership has any sense of a looming
challenge. Prediction processing
framework is determined by three
categorical imperatives. First, upper
Echelon's prediction models and
predictions must be explainable.
Second, each of the hierarchical layers
must have formal and informal spaces,
coupling each layer to the next layer.
And third, the firm's generative model
is the firm's eco niche. Prediction
processing framework provides an
entirely new perspective and language
embracing strategic renewal as a matter
of bottom up, top down prediction errors
minimization, not least, setting free
the full potential of the human machine
interface. And it's interesting here,
like, I wonder what he means by human
machine interface. Like humans as a
functioning machine, as an organism
maybe, or as like,
I don't know, or directly like the human
computer introduction, like how we
interface with our technology. So I was
curious. I found this human machine
interface clause kind of like threw me
force a loop a little bit. You guys know
any comments?
I kind of been inferring that Bijan
imagines a world where you're very tied
in with the AI and I personally haven't
witnessed this myself. Like being in and
organization where that is like a
seamless integration where you might use
a machine learning framework, but rather
that it is like a dialogue between the
ML model and then the human. I think
that's what he's kind of imagining, but
I think it's a little bit unclear. I
think you're right. Bleu so I've
studied and taken courses and
intelligence with people who study.
Their course of study is like human
computer introduction, like the
interface between humans and machines.
And it's always like their topics
of study are very different than
thinking about themselves. As a firm.
They think about their topic of study,
like interacting with a wellness robot.
Like, you've seen the health little
robot for elderly people that checks up
on them. And how do elderly people best
interact with computers and children?
And they have a very different level of
interaction, both like the older
generation and kids. They have different
ways to interact and interface with
computers and they do it best in an
embodied kind of machine, which I found
super interesting in the mid range. We
can just talk to, we have no problem
talking to Alexa and it could just be
like a microchip like speaker in the
wall and it wouldn't be a big deal. But
they want something in a teddy bear or
some kind of machine that looks as a
face or something like that and they
interact with it in a much different
way, much more efficiently, actually.
So I found that super interesting. But
this is what I think about when I think
about the human machine interface is
like the actual Markov boundary between
humans and machines. And so what is the
potential of a Markov boundary? I don't
know. Anyway, so sorry I'm rambling.
Okay, so just a few keywords here.
Upper echelon view prediction processing
framework. We'll go back and revisit
double learning, look into optimization,
organizational sense making and I think
the biggest chunk of new information
that Bijan brought into this chapter.
What were these habits of mind? Okay,
so do you want to read this from
retailer Upper Echelon view? Cool. So
UEB defines the organization as a
reflection of its upper Echelon, ie.
Its top management team. Ueb's central
premise is that generative experiences,
values and personalities affect their
field of vision, their one field of
vision. The directors they look and
listen selective exteroception what they
actually see in here and three,
interpretation how they attach meaning
to what they see in here. So
essentially, UEV re embraces sensing and
sense making not only as an essential
leadership qualities, but as a
foundation for strategic choices and
firm performance.
Cool. And so there are a couple of
claims kind of associated with this
upper Echelon view. Bijan says however,
upper Echelon view suffers from several
limitations. In particular, there is no
explicit consideration for the board of
directors as part of the upper Echelon.
The many dimension by which a
nonexecutive chairman relates to the
CEO, for example, are likely to
determine strategic choices. He goes on
to say while Upper Echelon view has
neglected the board of directors, free
energy governance emphasizes the
importance of the board as part of a
firm's upper Echelon top management here
and the board of directors here,
jointly labeled as the upper Echelon are
together the locus of strategic decision
making. More importantly, the board of
directors can potentially assume a
unique cognitive role in strategy
process in the form of dynamic board
capabilities that is highly
complementary to that of senior
executive leadership. Strategic capacity
and I was wondering, Tyler, maybe if you
have any concepts here on like normally
the board is not included as the upper
echelon and Bijan is making the case for
their inclusion. Is that typical in
organizations or what do you think here?
No, that's not common. And I think Bijan
touched on this in our last call with
him. The last discussion is that usually
you see the board as more of like a
sounding board, as that they give a
final sign off a rubber stamp, they make
sure you're not doing anything totally
illegal and irresponsible, but they're
not really there to really be in the
weeds with you. Whereas what the genre
is arguing is like, no, actually, by
virtue of being kind of separate from
the day to day work, they can give you a
more unbiased view of what you should be
doing strategically, like the
capabilities you should be building,
and that they actually are, like, a
really integral part of your whole
strategic process. And so it's unusual
to think of them as these two really
critical halves. Usually people think of
the board as this nuisance that they
have to appease, not as a real thing
that can actually add value to the
organization.
Awesome. Thank you for that input.
Okay, so a couple more things to say
about UEV and we just kind of excerpted
from the text. Upper echelon view is far
too restrictive and one sided top down
to explain through the lens of
leadership qualities the anatomy of
success and failure of strategic
renewal. This book invites to a new
stream of upper echelon youth centric
research that operationalize upper
echelon youth impact on firm
performance. Not so much in terms of
antecedents and consequences of team
diversity, but as a function of
structure, cognitively coupling,
governance and operational channels in
the form of top down, bottom up,
circular prediction, error,
minimization, second cognition,
embracing environment. As a matter of
action centric enactment and third
capabilities. Developing duality
management as a dynamic board.
Capability to rewire the plane while
flying it. He goes on to say the
prediction processing framework allows
us to embrace structure more
holistically. I don't know if you guys
have any comments here. Daniel?
Let's just say that we're in a
tripartite firm with the upper etchelon
consisting of the higher management and
or the board of directors, middle
management and then the front lines, as
Bijan mentioned last week, overly
emphasizing in a given eco niche.
Any one of those three sections is going
to lead to maladaptive decision making
and implementation. So the question
that I see these repeated structure
cognition capabilities returning to is
about striking an adaptive balance
amongst the upper etchelon.
The middle management implementation
layers and the frontline DayToday
experience, just like the body and the
organism, strike a balance between the
primary perceptual organs, the
intermediate processing and then the
central processing.
Cool. Thank you. All right, so moving
on to the prediction processing
framework tyler, do you want to read
this for us? Do you mind? All right. So
neither governance or strategic renewal
research have addressed the hierarchical
disconnect of the top down, bottom up
circular causality servant and
exceptional contributions aside,
PPF opens the processual black box
of how shared meaning and expectations
are constructed and optimized and
pursued optimizing the performance
sustainability of strategic renewal in
management science. PPF's biological
origins can be traced to Argus Agris's
theory of action perspective,
specifically the concept of double loop
learning. Defined as a form of learning
that challenges the existing routines
and status quo action centric learning
is at the heart of crosshair goal
prediction processing framework. There
is a need for fundamentally for a
fundamentally new organizing framework
system's preparedness to unlearn powers
the receptivity to correlation feedback
of the decisionmaking unit and hence is
critical to PPF's top down, bottom UPUP
learning prediction error minimization
challenge.
Cool. Daniel, do you have any comments
here? Yes. In Bayesian,
learning really is unlearning. You have
to move the distribution around. And so
Bayesian learning isn't just throwing
more papers onto a stack or onto a
knowledge pile, but when we have to
update how likely we think things are.
That is an unlearning. So it's
interesting to see how it's connected
here to openness to the unknown negative
capabilities and the way in which in the
single loop, which I know we'll get to,
you can implement and do local
maximization and maybe be locally
adaptive. But if we really want to pull
back and amidst these discontinuities
continue to find success, then we need
to engage in that kind of double loop
learning.
You totally took the words out of my
mouth and actually just said it so much
better. So I also was like really
reminded of Bayesian learning here with
unlearning because for all the reasons
we just stated. Okay, so double loop
learning just to read that. I think we
talked about this maybe not last week
with bjanda just a couple of weeks ago.
So double loop learning occurs when in
order to correct an error, it's
necessary to alter the governing values
of the master program. So in this little
figure, it's just like single loop
learning is action assess the
consequences, actions assess the
consequences, where the double loop
learning zooms out to kind of see like,
what governing variables influence the
actions that are being taken. So it's
kind of like the setback in a
hierarchical control model. And Bijan
says that we need error feedback loops
to adjust predictions and more
importantly, to eventually update
prediction models, aka double loop
learning.
So Bijan goes on to make the claim. He
says upper echelon remains the
centralized purveyor of predictions as
well as trustee of prediction models.
Hence, the prediction processing powered
free energy governance framework is
distributed at the bottom but
centralized at the top. However, for
prediction error minimization to work,
each hierarchical layer must be
dedicated to one simple first order
principle minimize free energy to
minimize error and surprise.
Consequently, prediction models will
generatively evolve by way of self
learning. This is the essence of
unsupervised self organization.
Any comments here? Sure. So in
terms of communication,
what are the different parts of the
organization or organism sharing with
each other? So they might just be
representing what they're perceiving.
Like everyone is just filling others in
on what they're getting. So that's one
imperative. It's just unbiased pass
through a communication. Another
generative might be give the other
person what they expect. So here the
management is saying we expect that
you're going to sell ten chaos and then
the front line says yes, we sold ten
cars.
Where free energy minimization as
a way to minimize or bound errors and
surprise comes in is that it says
actually the communication imperative
shouldn't be simple passthrough and it
also shouldn't be conformist. But rather
what is communicated should provide
information about to what extent the
expectations of your communicating
partner are being violated. So if
they say we expect ten cars,
the minimum communication might just be
yes, if that's true. And then maybe
there's a dial that can be turned
depending on whether it's fewer than
that or more than that. And so that puts
communication into an interesting
setting where we're explicit about what
the, in this case, top down predictions
are and then we situate the bottom up
communication as reflecting the adequacy
of those expectations rather than just
being plain passed through or
conformist. Yeah, just to
build on that a little bit. Because in
my experience there's, like you said,
they only two kinds of communication.
There's one of very clear, like hey,
this is what we're expecting, did you
meet that like a very clear prediction.
And there's another one that's more just
like dissonance. Like things just aren't
working well and people don't fully
understand why. And this is my
experience really trying to communicate
in a very clear linear way through each
stack of the hierarchy about trying to
warn someone of an issue, for example,
or communicate like the new world or how
you should update your generative model.
That tends to not work nearly as well as
just things not working well. And people
bumping up against discontinuities and
dissonance themselves and people feel
like, oh, there's like a problem in the
system, this is a signal that we need to
fix it. And usually that's in my
experience, like how communication
happens between the hierarchies and it
feels really bad and it feels very
chaotic. But ant the end of the day, I
think that's how the organism of the
firm processes information.
Yeah. It's asking too much for the
skin cell to provide a situational
report on the wound. All it can and
must do is report a difference from
expectation that gets clustered with
other incoming sensory modalities and
integrated by the upper echelon to make
a decision about, okay, now we're going
to get a bandaid. So understanding that
the skin cell is not going to tell you
to get a band and but also the bandaid
decision making unit isn't going to have
direct access to the skin,
can that be implemented at the firm
level?
I also am reminded of communication here
and how that coupling between
different layers of the hierarchy can I
talk today? The coupling between the
different layers of the hierarchy, how
should that work? So just for example,
the skin cell doesn't necessarily need
to know what is happening in the liver,
right? It's not like a direct coupling
there. How do you selectively
choose as a management, like what
to communicate down the chain? If I'm in
the upper echelon, what does the board
communicate to the top management tier?
What is the top management tier then
communicate downstream? And how do you
filter that information so that it's
like how do you prioritize salient here
and just not open up a
fire hose here's all the information?
Because that's not effective for
communicating. But also that disconnect,
like any kind of filtering can lead to a
level of disconnect that may be
unwanted. So how do you prioritize that
information flow down layers of the
hierarchy? And I always am interested in
this, whether it's biological or
organizational. I have a couple of
examples to allostat that. So for
example, I worked at a company called I
won't name any names here, but it was a
tech company and it was like very like
400 people. And it was like structured
very hierarchically. And so basically
from the bottom rungs to the top, you
would have each person would report up
to their unit and have like, hey, this
is what we did. These are like we're
risks you should be aware of, right?
And this would be happen on a weekly
basis and then that would get bubbled up
into the next running of the hierarchy,
which keeps getting synthesized and
refined at each level of the hierarchy
until you get up to the CEO, right?
Which is presumed like ostensibly like
condensing all of this information from
400 people up to one report, but the CEO
gets up like five bullets of takeaways,
right? And so like, what happens Bijan
even talks about this in the chapter is
that it gets so filtered by that point.
And also each rung in the hierarchy has
like their own incentives and things
that they're trying to like politically
maximize for that becomes like not even
that useful. So what's a lot more
useful though is when things, I guess
two things. One is if things go wrong,
let's say there's a bug in the app and
something, a firing needs to be put out
right away. That's information that
skips all the wrongs and goes straight
to the CEO. Another one is when people
would a lot of times executives would
schedule meetings, but just random
people in the organization. So you have
an executive who's like the CFO would
schedule a meeting with some engineer
and just to basically cross the chasm of
all the different levels of the
hierarchy. Just be like, hey, like,
what's going on? Like, tell me like,
what you perceive the problems to be in
your subunit. And that's a way for them
to kind of get like this unfiltered view
of like random people by sampling random
people across the organization. So I
think there are ways you can do this,
but yeah, it's really difficult.
Cool. Okay, so moving on, we'll talk a
little bit about optimization and I just
put up here, like the distributed versus
hierarchical levels,
the networks. Okay, so Bijan
the challenge is not only one of
building intra firm connections between
upper echelon's top down predictions and
field management bottom up stimuli, but
optimizing the top down, bottom up
process within each and every layer of
the hierarchy. Why did you say that?
Of the hierarchy? In form of feedback
connections, optimization is central to
prediction processing framework. This
optimization makes every level in the
hierarchy accountable to others. While
the generative sense making processes
and capabilities are a critical
performance element at every level of
the hierarchy, the efficacy of such
capabilities is determined by top down
belief propagation and bottom up message
passing within and across organizational
layers or business units.
Yeah, so I think that optimization for
maybe information or I
don't know, what are you optimizing the
connection, optimizing the flow of
information, optimizing the link between
up and down? What are we really
optimizing for? I don't know.
Yeah, it's a little bit vague in how he
talks about it and it's honestly
something I got kind of a little bit
frustrated with because actually
building that top down, bottom up kind
of connective tissue is like a huge area
of research and there's all these
different approaches for it. So like a
really famous one is Holocracy. I'm not
sure you guys are familiar with
Holocaust. Holocracy got famous because
it was implemented by Zappos to like mix
results potentially. But a cool way that
they do it is that it's not like a very
traditional pyramid hierarchical
structure that each subunit will kind of
dynamically form bonds with other levels
of the hierarchy, kind of arbitrarily
depending on needs as they arise. But
they have a whole system for how those
bonds can form and how you generate
links across different levels of the
hierarchy. And so that's just to say
this is like a huge area of research and
experimentation that no one really has
like a great answer for. And yeah,
this is like a huge open
ended question.
There's no general strategy for a bug,
so it doesn't seem like there's going to
be a general organization chart or
Communications platform.
And technology is changing so rapidly.
And intelligence augmentation. This is
helping us sketch the first lines
on our notebook that takes us into a
discussion and an adaptive process and
that is the reframing of the strategy
governance conversation. It's not this
is the strategy playbook,
it's not the homework problems but
it's bringing some ideas to the table
that are mixing it up.
So I don't know, I think about
optimizing sense making at each level
because of the quote that's stated here
and so how do you optimize sense
making across layers? It definitely has
to do with information prioritization,
I think, but it's
like how to selectively choose. I guess
it's like a very open ended question but
I don't know. I would like some concrete
examples. It's something like I would
like to drill Bijan on have you ever
seen this done and like what worked and
what didn't? As far as optimizing this
hierarchy flow. As to
what is being optimized. One sort of
capital maximalist approach is like
profit is to be maximized or risk
discounted profit or a triple bottom
line. There are imperatives for the
organization to optimize but that
doesn't Dean that. That becomes the
imperative at every communication step.
And kind of the dream or direction
of informational free energy
minimization would be you'll be doing
as good as you can in the niche. From
like an energetics and metabolism
perspective when you're informationally
optimizing, if you're a bear making the
best possible decisions, you will
survive in the niche. And so it's kind
of like recognizing the difference
between the ecological success of
an communication or organism.
Recognizing that that embodied success
and death isn't the informational
imperative but for things
that work and not things that don't,
fulfilling the informational imperative
should lead to the embodied success
because it's defined in that way.
So it's easy to turn to maximizing
profit as a firm objective. But I think
that is short sighted. I definitely
think that there's many other things
like if you're making the most possible
money of producing light bulbs, say I'm
making a light Bull and I'm maximizing
profit on the light Bull and I'm
producing a million of them for pennies,
right? And they're selling for $10 each
or whatever. But I'm like polluting a
river because I'm making the light Bull
so cheap. I'm not adequately disposing
of waste or whatever. Then that's going
to have blowback later either through
EPA or through customers saying I don't
want that because it's not sustainable.
So if you're just exploitative or
exploitative then it's not going to work
out in the long run. So maximizing
profit is a very delicate thing,
especially in terms of company
persistence and sustainability. Like
sustainability not like an eco friendly
way but like sustainability of the
company itself.
Sorry, I was thinking of fermenting
bacteria. Initially certain strategies
work but then that can lead to the
production of metabolites that that
strategy will no longer be optimal in.
So one has to consider like
externalities in the niche. And of
course all of this is just a statistical
framework. That's way before we get into
ethical imperatives or preferences.
Yeah, this is what I think we covered in
the third Livestream. But it's like,
okay, how do you hurt cats
basically and get all these different
levels of the organization to move in
the same direction and kind of balance
that these different things. You might
want to optimize for that in the long
term. Maybe it goes for profit but you
might have sub problems that you need to
solve that are not strictly profit. And
so one of the most famous ways of doing
this is OKR, so like objective key
results at your top level of the
organization. Maybe it is profit or
maybe it is like some kind of double
bottom line. But then as you go into sub
units of the organization like say you
have customer service, your customer
service team is not optimizing for
profit. They're optimizing for a
customer experience score like CSAT for
example, right? And your legal team is
not optimizing for profit. They have
their own measure that they're
optimizing for the number of cases they
win or legal risk avoided. I don't
know how you quantify that, but there
are ways that you can kind of break the
bigger the problem of profit into sub
problems and rather than having
everyone going towards profit ant the
same time.
All right, so perfectly perfect setting
into organizational sense making. So
I'll read this organizational sense
making is not about optimally
approximating an objectively defined
external reality but developing and
enacting models of reality by way of top
down, bottom up predictive coding.
Effectively the future arrives in the
present and becomes the past. Time moves
at different rates in the brain's
hierarchy as is true for the firm.
While time has strictly no speed.
Humans project speed onto time as
relations and interactions increase in
intensity and complexity. A firm's very
existence is determined by its curiosity
field interaction with its external
environment. Fast at the reflex low
level I. E. Resource markets and more
slowly at higher cognitive levels I. E.
Strategic decision making. And this
reminds me of like a paper that Daniel
and I have been working on and just how
temporarily active inference and the FEP
operates at different fast and slow.
It kind of reminds me of how in pretty
much every company I think I've ever
worked ant there's always this tendency
for the bottom rung of the organization
to think that the top wrong are just
like a bunch of flow bumbling idiots.
There's this temporal disconnect of the
bottom rung of the organization is
getting feedback immediately and they're
running little tiny experiments every
single day where they're getting
immediate feedback whereas the top rung
is like the board. Maybe they're meeting
quarterly and then they have some
mandate and they don't really get
feedback synthesized to them until like
another three months. And so there's
always this tendency for there's always
this temporal disconnect and it always
creates this kind of boundary disconnect
between the bottom and. Top of the
organization. This point
of time having no speed is quite
interesting. We talk about the food is
taking too slow or slower time
scales. Faster time scales, longer
distances. It feels natural
to talk about the rate of speed,
but even without going into too much
reconceptualizations of speed, it just
isn't necessarily that way. And then in
the brain as to like, time moves at
different rates in the brain's
hierarchy, we could think about a neural
firing pattern that takes place over
some number of milliseconds. And then
there's slower waves and rhythms.
They compose and they influence each
other. They're all happening at once.
Technically it's all happening in the
same way at the same place, the same
exact input outputs. But still
it makes sense to talk about some of
these slower or larger waves and some
faster waves, like in the EEG rhythms.
So striking a balance between everything
all at once, real time unfolding.
And then these day, week, month,
year, decade, nested timescales is a
big part of sense making.
Definitely. Okay, habits of mind. So I
like this because I've read good to
great. The Jim Collins book. And when
Tyler and I were first starting out this
series, we talked about how that's very
leader centric and very top down the
ideas that are presented in that book.
And so I was excited to see this book.
Good to great to Gone by Alan Wertzel.
I have not read it, but he talks about
companies like, I think specifically
like Circuit City is the company,
right? Oh, yeah, it's here on the COVID
of the book. But Circuit City was like
one of the companies that Jim Collins
went through and Good to Great and then
now there is no more Circuit City. And
so he, I guess, kind of outlines the
failings of what makes a good company a
great company, and now they're obsolete
and maybe why they're obsolete. And so
he outlines these habits of mind and
I haven't read the book and I don't know
enough, but they're listed here if you
want to read them and maybe read the
book. But these habits of mind that are
necessary to stay relevant maybe
so. Bijan says that habits of mind may
equally explain why upper echelon is
generally resisting strategy process as
a matter of top down, bottom up,
prediction, error, implication. And he
goes on to make the claim that five out
of work sold. Twelve habits of mind are
foundational to prediction processing
framework, fostering success of
strategic renewal. And he briefly
summarizes these habits. Tyler, do you
want to read these for us? Sure. So,
first one be humble, run scared. So
continuously doubt your understanding of
things. Business success contains the
seeds of its own destruction. Two,
curiosity sustains the cat. The world is
constantly changing. Be open and curious
and stretch to learn from others. Three
evidence trump's ideology. In business,
as in politics, decisions are too often
based on unproven assumptions about what
works and what doesn't. We all need
operating assumptions about human
nature, the economy and the like. But
when things do not work out as planned,
we need to determine whether our
assumptions were based on evidence or
ideology. Four confront the Ronen facts.
The worst person you can fool is
yourself. Ignoring or denying reality
does not help it go away. Five chasing
possible dream do not be limited by the
tyranny of the or.
So I thought this was cool. I think a
lot of these habits of mind speak to the
ability to rewire the plane while flying
it. I don't know what the Dean stressed
earlier in the chapter. Do you guys have
any additional comments here?
All right. Okay. So another
claim, and this might be who might be
getting close to agent? Okay. Bijan says
it is the circular causality of belief
propagation message passing where
prediction processing framework
effectiveness in the organizational
context most likely breaks down.
Neither the bottom up message passing
nor the top down belief propagation are
unobstructed. We fail to appreciate how
organizational friction, which he
defines as high levels of free energy,
compromise firm performance due to,
first, top down enforced predictions and
prediction models that are not receptive
to bottom up challenge. Second, leak top
down, bottom up lateral generative
sensing and sense we can capabilities in
the form of error signaling and
processing and third, poor communication
and absence of a language that is
suitable to leverage prediction
processing framework for strategic
renewal. So I thought that that was kind
of neat, like how
these are the faults, right? And then he
goes on to say, in the organizational
context, prediction processing framework
is determined by three categorical
imperatives. And I've abbreviated these
kind of just shortening them so that
they fit on the slide. First, upper
echelon's prediction models and
corresponding predictions must be
explainable and explicitly articulated.
And yeah,
so that goes into the communication
salience prioritization. He says the
language and Communications layers are
critical to resource conversation, firm
performance, and eventually firm
survival. He also says each of the
hierarchical layers must have formal and
informal interfaces that couple each
layer to the next layer. For a given
hierarchical structure of a firm to have
any legitimacy, generative, top down,
bottom up sensing and sense making at
every hierarchical level should equally
make sense before an error message
travels to the next level. There should
not and cannot be any bypassing of
hierarchical layers. I guess that's,
like, don't go over someone's head. But
also, I wonder about
the bypassing, about the information
flow and the throughput and how big does
that channel have to be? And lastly, he
says the firm's generative model is the
firm's eco niche. When we perceive the
world as uncertain and unpredictable,
it is a mere reflection of the
inadequacy of our generative reality
model. So I think that that's how to
avoid the errors mentioned in the
previous slide.
Any comments here. Final thoughts on the
material. One thought is I like number
one, we're talking about how you get to
articulate and communicate top down,
like what your actual model is so it can
be challenged. And something that I've
noticed is that oftentimes people will
communicate their predictions, but not
necessarily how those predictions were
generated or the components of that,
like the components of the assumptions
that went into that prediction. And that
makes it really hard for other levels of
the hierarchy to even know what was
going on and what they should be
challenging at all. And a lot of times
you'll just assume like, okay, they
probably know what they're talking
about, they're the experts, so let's
just hope for the best. But I really
like that he said no, you have to
explicitly say what your model is so it
can be challenged.
To the going over someone's head.
On a previous slide it said
organizational friction is high free
energy. We might want to finesse that by
saying relatively high free energy
because in general we're not interested
in the absolute value of a free energy
calculation, but rather the gradients
and the direction at which we could act
to improve or increase it. So it's not
about the total amount, it's about the
relative amount. So let's just say it
turned out that somebody from an.org
chart perspective did go over their
head. That could be understood as a
policy selection authorized or dot two,
structurally rewire the communication
architecture of the firm. Now that
rewiring in a situation may
be associated with a decrease in
organizational friction and therefore a
decrease in the free energy. So it may
be an adaptive decision because no chaos
is the final word. But that doesn't mean
that every time somebody tries to rewire
the Communications architectures, it
would decrease friction if people were
just getting all these side messages and
there would be so many issues as well.
So it's not to say to do or not to
do. It's giving the areas of
consideration, the structure, cognitive
and capacity oriented aspects that we
can have that ongoing conversation and
some principles that help us take
selection and still do things in an
uncertain world with this little fun
caveat that the perception of the world
as uncertain and unpredictable is
actually and inadequacy of our
generative reality. I mean, even
skipping different levels of hierarchy
could be something that you explicitly
plan for as well and build processes
around. So for example, I worked at a
company that they call it like the big
red button. Whereas if you were at the
bottom right of the organization and you
saw something that was going terribly
wrong, you could basically push this big
red button and it would file this report
directly to the C suite and would skip
all the levels and then they would
follow up with you directly. And so they
explicitly said like, hey, we know that
there can be things that are shielded
from our view and we want to know about
it. And they build a process explicitly
around it.
Sorry. Go ahead, Daniel. That reminds me
of cells signaling. And then the
ultimate red button is like when the
cellular contents are spilling out,
it's like my only message to share is
that I am no longer and all
my insides are spilling on to you. So
it's like if there's a protein that's
usually internal and you're being bathed
in it, that's the red button that you
needed. So, yes, that kind of emergence
or conditional rewiring,
maybe there's many patterns and motifs
where we might want to embed that kind
of flexibility. Hinton the
Communications architectures. So even
though it is a dynamic Communications
architecture at a higher level, it's
actually not changing in its dynamics.
Like, different people are going to be
in different video calls, but that
doesn't mean that the Communications
architectural plan is changing. It just
means that different individuals are
connected differently.
So in terms of sharing the model,
Tyler, when you were talking about
sharing how the top level will share
their predictions, but not necessarily
how those predictions were generated,
I'm, like, really reminded of academic
research in which it's like, I feel like
everyone is so, like, shielded from
what's going on. Like, you have the
principal investigator, they write a
grant. The grant has like, three
specific games. Just an example. So then
those three specific games, each grad
student will be working on one of the
aims, right? Or maybe they'll have a
team working on achieving one of the
three specific aims. Right? And like,
these teams are doing totally, like,
work that they think is totally
unrelated. Like, they have no idea,
like, the overarching process of the
grant. I wonder how often the Pi shares
the entire grant with every student.
That's not something that I typically
see. And I think that there's a lot of
shielding going on and I don't really
know why. Is it because it's just too
much information or because they just
want the focus to be on that one thing
they want the students to have this
myopic view, and I just wonder Daniel,
what is your experience there? Do you
think that PiS generally share the
entire model or they just share a piece
of it? What is your experience, and do
you think that that makes research
dysfunctional?
Interesting? I've seen some
investigators who shared the grants or
other encoding strategy documents or
not. It reminds me of a computer
program. Like if you could perfectly
isolate every variable and for loop,
and you can really clearly say, this is
the scope of this script and all of
that. That may work in a computer
system, but humans are
always curious about the concept and the
past and the culture and alternate
futures. So that kind of
strict indoctrination, encapsulation
approach might increase overhead,
decrease concept, have to spend a lot of
time re explaining things.
It's not that one strategy is going to
be, in general, better than the other,
but it seems like it could be a better
professional conversation if the lab
strategy governance were framed in a way
that accounting for people's differences
in, like, familiarity with grant writing
or with experiment design, at least
giving lab level awareness. Doesn't seem
like it'd be a bad thing. Yeah, there's
an analogous problem within a business
organization and some of the type of
like OKRs, where you take this big goal
you have, let's say it's growth and you
split it up into sub component parts.
So one problem I've had in one
organization actually multiple
organizations, is on the growth funnel.
So like how you get leads and then how
you convert them into actual conversions
and sales. Right? And so what often
happens is that there's a trade off
between getting more leads and the
quality of those leads. And so what
you'll do is you'll have a top level
growth initiative, like we have to grow
by 10% and then you're like cool. Like
marketing people increase your leads and
then product people increase the
conversion on this funnel. But what
actually happens though is if the
marketing team increases their leads,
they often get more poor quality leads.
Like you're dipping into lower quality
leads to increase your leads. And so
that actually reduces the conversation
of the next step of the funnel. And so
they're both narrowly optimized on their
one little piece of the puzzle, but they
actually really directly impact each
other. And then you get into these like
really painful conversations between
your marketing team and your growth
product team, which is like really like
if they were just had this like more
holistic view to begin with, it's like,
no, we're just trying to grow guys.
Like that's what we're trying to do. We
don't care about your little piece of
the puzzle. And so there's often this
time where by breaking things off too
narrowly, you really miss the bigger
picture. And this is super common.
Yeah.
Well, having the a priori
partitioning means that you are saying
like.
Not. Even the structure of the problem
is going to change again, if you only
have to partition the problem one time,
then maybe it can be cut and dry.
But those kinds of dependencies are
why we need these kinds of composable
partitioning strategies so that
different parts of a Bayes graph can be
identified because we're looking at a
lot of text, but all of these notions of
a generative model, generative process.
We can also see that kind of a Bayes
graph representation in the background,
especially as these types of
perspectives move closer to application.
Awesome. Well, that's the end of the
content here for chapter six. We will
delve into chapter seven next week.
Unless you guys have any final things to
say, that's it for me. So thanks for,
for being here. And I'm looking forward
to Carrying on Pushing forward,
learning more about free energy
governance and future discussions with
the author.
All right, thank you. Till next time.